>> That's a good answer, David. Note that David did several things in coming up
with his answer. First, he made sure that his answer covers all these signs and
symptoms. This is the principle of coverage. We want to make
sure that the diagnostic conclusion actually accounts for all the input data.
Second, we chose a single hypothesis over a combination of hypothesis, although
the combination could have explain this data as well. This is the principle of
parsimony. In general, we want a simple hypothesis for explaining the entire
data. Third, these hypotheses can have greatest interactions between them, and
these interactions can make your diagnostic task quite complicated.
Fourth, they would use the term explanation. This is an important aspect for
diagnosis. We want a set of hypotheses that could explain the input data.
Now this [UNKNOWN] we did it in this simple exercise, because there is one
single disease that can, in fact, explain all the input data. What would
happen if there was no single hypothesis that could cover the entire input data?
Or what would happen if there were multiple hypotheses that could equally well
explain the input data? [UNKNOWN] diagnostic task can be quite complicated.